the middle east peace process is a
special issue for norway this month's
president of the security council the
country brokered the oslo accords almost
30 years ago in fact norway's ambassador
mona jules sitting behind the foreign
minister who chaired the meeting played
an instrumental role in mediation at the
time
the un envoy tor wenisland is also a
norwegian and he reacted to the latest
israeli action
fifteen members of a family in sheikh
gerar a palestinian neighborhood in east
jerusalem were dragged from their home
it was then demolished just hours before
the security council meeting
i still remain concerned
by the potential eviction of a number of
palestinian families from homes they
have lived in for decades in sieger and
sinbad neighborhoods of east jerusalem
and the risk that such actions pose for
escalating violence
i call on israeli authorities to end the
displacement and evictions of
palestinians in line with its obligation
under international law
israel's ambassador to the un brought a
large rock to the security council
meeting saying it was a palestinian
terrorist weapon a palestinian diplomat
later remarked to me perhaps our side
should bring a fighter jet next time to
show the weapons the israelis use
outside the council chamber i asked the
israeli ambassador to explain his
government's actions in sheikh jarrah
in regards to what you asked me about
the supposed
evictions again israel is a law-abiding
country we have a very respected and
responsible and independent
legal system you don't abide by u.n
security council resolutions that's
international our our legal system is
is
respected internationally and our courts
are
as i said independent norway had called
this as a ministerial meeting of the
security council to refocus attention on
one of the world's longest standing
conflicts
cobit is clearly a factor but out of the
15 council members only ghana and norway
itself sent their foreign ministers
the palestinian foreign minister was not
critical of that but when he spoke to
reporters he did express his
disappointment at the biden
administration in the first year in
office he'd hoped the new president
would have done more to restart
diplomacy
james bay's al jazeera at the united
nations